un débat final beaucoup moins
cacophonique que ne fut le premier débat
entre joe biden et donald trump les deux
candidats ont fait davantage preuve de
courtoisie il se sont - couper la parole
mais ils ne se sont pas échangé des
politesses
pour autant des attaques frontales même
parfois personnelles ont été échangés
lors de ce débat avec donc six thèmes
abordés ce soir avec notamment la
gestion de la pandémie due qu'aux vide
19 joe biden a attaqué donald trump sur
sa gestion de la pandémie tandis que le
président américain a rétorqué en
affirmant qu'un vaccin serait bientôt
disponible pour la population américaine
écouter ce premier extrait du débat deux
cent vingt mille américains morts
si vous n'entendez rien d'autre de ce
que je dis ce soir
écoutez ceci quelqu'un qui est
responsable de ne pas avoir pris le
contrôle
à vrai dire d'avoir dit au début je ne
prends aucune responsabilité
quelqu'un qui est responsable d'autant
de mort ne devrait pas pouvoir rester
président des états unis d'amérique
j'ai dit que nous apprenions à vivre
avec
nous n'avons pas le choix on ne peut pas
se confiner dans un sous sol comme le
fait de joe hill a la capacité de
s'enfermer je ne sais pas il a à
l'évidence gagner beaucoup d'argent
quelque part mais lui il peut vivre dans
un sous sol
les gens ne peuvent pas faire ça même en
tant que président je ne pouvais pas
faire ça j'adorerais me mettre dans un
sous sol dont une belle pièce de la
maison blanche et attendre pendant un an
et demi que ça disparaisse
je ne peux pas faire ça le débat qui a
pris ensuite un virage important
puisqu'il a été question de la sécurité
nationale des états unis et à travers ce
thème beaucoup d'autres en ont découlé a
notamment été question de possibles
ingérences dont sont accusés des pays
comme la russie la chine ou encore tout
récemment l'iran et sur ce sujet là et
les échanges ont été particulièrement
musclée écouter à nouveau cette passe
d'armes entre donald trump et joy ride
mais vous receviez beaucoup d'argent de
la russie
vous payez beaucoup d'argent et ils le
feront probablement encore mais
maintenant avec ce qui est sorti
aujourd'hui c'est encore pire
tous ces emails les email les horribles
email solo type d'argent que vous
ramassiers vous et votre famille et joe
vous étiez vice-présidence dans tout
cela est arrivé et cela n'aurait jamais
dû arriver et je pense que vous devez
une explication aux américains ce projet
mise en oeuvre la politique américaine
pas une seule chose n'était hors des
clous pas une seule chose premièrement
deuxièmement le type qui a eu des ennuis
en ukraine était ce type qui essayait de
coron pour le gouvernement ukrainien
pour qu'il dise quelque chose de négatif
à mon sujet ce qu'il ne ferait pas et
n'a pas fait parce que cela ne s'est
jamais produit monfils n'a pas gagné
d'argent grâce à ce qu'il dit de la
chine
je n'ai pas eu le seul gars qui a gagné
de l'argent en chine
est ce gala mais forcément puisqu'il
était question de puissance étrangère et
de leurs possibles interférences dans la
politique nationale américaine la sphère
de joe biden et de son fils a été mis
sur la table ou fait un bref rappel des
faits l'ancien vice président est accusé
d'avoir eu un lien avec les affaires de
son fils hunter byden lorsque celui ci
travaillait en ukraine cela se passe au
moment où je bailon était vice président
des états unis et depuis plusieurs jours
la polémique ne faiblit pas avec
notamment un ordinateur portable qui
aurait appartenu à hunter biden qui
serait désormais dans les mains du fbi y
aille dans le cadre d'une enquête
évidemment donald trump n'a pas manqué
d'interroger le vice président l'ancien
vice président américain sur ce sujet en
écoute c'est très clair que dans cette
élection
je ne parle même pas de la précédente
dans cette élection la russie a été
impliqué la chine a été impliqué aussi
dans une certaine mesure et maintenant
nous apprenons que l'iran est impliqué
ils paieront un prix si je suis élu il
interfère avec la souveraineté
américaine
il n'y a eu personne de plus dure contre
la russie avec les sanctions personnes
de plus dur que moi sur la russie entre
les sanctions entre tout ce que j'ai
fait avec l'otan
savez j'ai demandé aux pays de l'otan de
mettre 130 milliards de plus pour passer
à 4 120 milliards de dollars par an
c'est pour me prémunir contre la russie
j'ai vendu pendant que lui vendait des
oreillers et des draps - j'ai vendu des
chars d'assaut à l'ukraine
il n'y a eu personne de plus dure envers
la russie que donald trump puis se sont
succédé les thèmes de l'économie de la
question raciale de l'immigration encore
de la question environnementale alors
sur ces thématiques
on a assisté à une opposition plutôt
attendu chacun des candidats soutenant
finalement ses positions maiden qui a
assez régulièrement mis en avant les
contradictions d'un président qu'il
considère comme mettant de l'huile sur
le feu sur les questions du racisme
tandis que donald trump répondu en
expliquant qu'il était la personne la
moins raciste de cette salle on rappelle
que ce débat se déroulait à nashville
dans le tennessee et puis dans l trump a
à plusieurs reprises pointé le bilan de
joe biden lorsque celui ci était vice
président des états unis alors rien
n'indique que ce débat pourra faire
bouger les lignes puisqu'il faut savoir
qu'il ya déjà près de 50 millions
d'électeurs américains qui ont voté un
vote par anticipation particulièrement
prisée en cette période de pandémie leur
va être désormais au décryptage à
l'analyse des arguments de chacun des
candidats et puis chacun se fera son
avis sur celui qu'ils considèrent comme
être le vainqueur de ce débat à moins de
quinze jours maintenant du scrutin